tu penses que c'est la première fois que
quelqu'un pointe une arme sur ma tempe
tu vas me faire rire mais je déteste
être en
retard  les forfaits
qu'est-ce que c'est que vous devriez sortir dans la voiture
vous tous maintenant
personne ne sort de la voiture maintenant
conduire voir ceinturer
peut-être que nous retravaillerons ensemble à l'
avenir
ce n'est pas K devant nous la
banque méditerranéenne a déjà été
cambriolée mais jamais  comme ce
chauffeur il est connu comme le transporteur nous
lui ferons payer puis-je
vous aider vous et vos amis
m'avez pris quelque chose et je vous ai pris
quelque chose je vous donne 12
heures pour trouver un père avant de le tuer
Je le pense parce que si vous répondez comme
ça alors nous allons voir karasov avons-nous le
choix
oh ça
arrive vraiment
nous aurons besoin de plus d'hommes
ce qui vous a pris si
longtemps quelques bébés difficiles à mettre